ça m'a vraiment permis de voyager déjà
c'est mon deuxième voyage et d'échanger
avec les autres cultures
je suis issue d'une famille d'artisans
ferronnier donc depuis tout petit en
fabrique des trucs avec les marteaux
tout ce qui a porté demain voilà pour
fabriquer des poupées et tout ça en
beaucoup dans l'art plastique et il y a
aussi mes parents qui m'a vraiment
poussé à aller dans ce sens là il y a
pas de des côtes d'art à Madagascar mais
après le bac mes parents voilà ils ont
dit tu fais ce que tu veux même si tu
veux faire que de l'art tu peux faire ça
donc c'était un gros choix à faire de de
tout laisser tomber de se focaliser sur
l'art
[Musique]
il y avait un événement qui s'était
passé dans ma vie donc ça m'a bouleversé
à partir de là je voulais raconter ma
propre histoire et c'est comme ça que
j'ai pu justement avoir le prix
parithana parce que j'avais quelque
chose à dire
j'ai raconté une histoire à partir de ça
donc avant j'étais que sur la peinture
mais
la gravure ça m'a paru comme ça la
peinture c'est très léger quand je peins
je fais ça ça mais la gravure ça me
permet on va dire d'immortaliser ou de
cicatriser le truc il y a beaucoup
d'énergie dedans et senti directement ah
c'est ça s'exprimer ah c'est ça créer et
voilà je pense que quand on le fait avec
le coeur comme ça c'est là qu'on ressent
et qu'on trouve cette
identité qu'on cherche tout le temps et
voilà j'ai commencé à forger mon
identité comme ça et c'est à partir de
ce moment là que j'ai fait de la
pyrogravure pour graver justement comme
des cicatrices et j'ai pas voulu laisser
la peinture non plus donc j'ai essayé de
mélanger les deux et sur les toiles
ça revient encore en ce moment
[Musique]
elle parle de d'une solitude parfaite on
va dire par exemple hier j'étais au
stade avec l'euphorie du moment et toute
la foule qui est là là on est super
content et tout à coup on pense aux
personnes qui ne sont plus là qui sont
ailleurs et c'est un moment qu'on veut
partager avec vous avec eux donc il y a
cette sensation de grande joie et cette
tristesse voilà comme une grosse vague
et c'est cette sensation que je voulais
immortaliser vraiment entre ces deux-là
[Musique]
moi je sais jamais où s'arrêter quand je
fais une toile donc artiste peintre on
n'est jamais vraiment satisfait de son
travail mais il faut du recul pour ça
voilà
[Musique]